[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre pour
un nouveau 7,8 loisirs chaque ce jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines au
sommaire de cette semaine vous devenez
enquêteur en 1919 un vol de bijoux a eu
lieu dans un hôtel particulier parisien
au même moment la paix est signé à
versailles un suspect est vite identifié
à vous de résoudre denim avec les
archives départementales
les journées européennes du patrimoine
vous débutez tour d'horizon du programme
dans le département excusez moi ce n'est
pas le bon texte et l'agenda complet de
mots sortent il y aura notamment du
sport course à pied et solidarité on
débute avec deux rendez-vous qui
commence ce week-end à rambouillet tout
d'abord où les animaux seront plus que
présent ce week-end c'est le sixième
festif photo cinquante deux expositions
sont répartis dans divers lieux de la
commune
la lanterne la bergerie nationale ou
encore la salle patenôtre des
photographies et des tableaux qui se
répondent
autour d'une problématique sensibilisés
à l'environnement et aux espèces en
danger le festival se déroule du 27 au
29 septembre
quand on représente les animaux
représentent le monde et les hommes et
bien sûr à la fois et c'est cette
proposition là que nous avons retenu en
fait sur laquelle nous sommes arrêtés et
qui donne cette superbe exposition très
colorée comme vous le verrez est tout à
fait parlons aussi en termes de
problématiques sur le monde actuel
quels sont les dangers que courent les
différentes espèces aujourd'hui comment
les caractériser dans une représentation
picturale
voilà des questions que les hommes se
posent depuis le début de l'humanité en
fait à chatou des milliers d'objets
attendent les passionnés du 27 septembre
au 6 octobre c'est la 99e édition de la
foire de chatou 800 stands accueilleront
les 300000 visiteurs la plus ancienne
brocante de france s'intéresse cette
année aux affiches des années 80 un mot
de son président au micro d'aurélie rose
chaque marchand quand il ya un thème et
bien ils essayent d'avoir quelque chose
de ce thème
vous allez retrouver cette année dans
les stands à certains même dans beaucoup
de stands des choses des années 80 un
collectionneur il trouve son bonheur
un amateur d'art il trouve son bonheur
un amateur de de vintage comme on
appelle y trouve son bonheur
en fait on a tous et c'est un village
pour entendre et l'interview direction
le site internet le 7 une culture de la
semaine précédente
si vous êtes plutôt du genre gourmand
est fan de chocolat la semaine car idées
pour vous c'est la semaine des
chocolatiers qui revient pour sa
deuxième édition du 30 septembre au 6
octobre
le travail des artisans est mis à
l'honneur les yvelinois ne sont bien sûr
pas en reste l'artisan du chocolat
olivier roy d'or à la reine astrid les
chocolats cola ou encore au roi soleil
vous attendent pour des visites et des
dégustations
toutes les informations sont à retrouver
sur le site internet
[Musique]
on poursuit ce magazine avec le notre
invité nous a rejoint le plateau romain
du gabon jours bonsoir
alors vous êtes le chef de service au
public des archives départementales et
vous propose au public un nouveau jeu
une véritable enquête policière tout à
fait à partir du 25 septembre donc ça a
débuté depuis un jour l'idée de
d'enquêté encore une fois comme dans
gueule d'ange cette fois ci on se plonge
sur la période des traités de paix de
versailles qui ont lieu en 1919
comme vous l'avez rappelé un vol de
bijoux a été commis à paris et un
suspect est rapidement appréhendé il
sera entendu par la police
et vous allez en participant à ce
concours aider la police à vérifier les
dires du suspect pour s'assurer s'il est
coupable ou non donc ce concours est
ouvert jusqu'au 18 octobre
il s'adresse aussi bien aux collégiens
yvelinois qu'au grand public donc de
deux possibilités de participer et puis
de nombreux lots sont à gagner par un
tout petit peu plus tard mais cette
histoire de vol c'est une histoire
réelle ou c'est une histoire inventée
alors c'est une histoire inventée
sachant néanmoins que
l'effet sur lequel on s'appuie pour
cette enquête sont basées sur des faits
réels et en tout cas le joueur sera
amené à décrypter les informations et à
décoder ce qui a été dit par le biais de
sources réelles et d'art chiffres
disponibles en ligne sur notre site
internet de sources réelles et puis pas
des moindres vous baser sur un événement
historique très célèbres dont on a fêté
le centenaire tout à fait traité de
versailles le traité de versailles qui a
eu lieu le 23 juin 1919 qui met fin à la
guerre entre l'allemagne et les alliés
il ya aussi le traité de saint germain
qui a eu lieu le 10 septembre 1919 donc
à l'occasion de ces traités on avait
l'occasion l'opportunité de clore un
petit peu les commémorations du
centenaire de la grande guerre sur
lequel nous avons été très actifs et
donc nous avons basé cette année
l'énigme sur cette période et le
concours permettra justement
d'appréhender des documents de cette
période sur notre site et de chercher
des informations de croiser les sources
à travers les archives disponibles en
ligne justement sur ce sur ce jeu on a
les techniques que vous aviez appris au
public avec gueule d'ange en à dire les
extraits de naissance de mariage et aux
et là on va plus loin on va vraiment
dans de l'iconographie aussi on va alors
les sources seront sans doute encore
plus variées je veux pas dévoiler les
sources au sein desquels il faudra
chercher les informations mais en tout
cas oui potentiellement il faut creuser
sur l'ensemble de notre site et
appréhender des sources aussi bien
photographique iconographiques et bien
sûr des sources un peu plus traditionnel
des sources écrites
voilà sachant que on imagine que
l'énigme soit pérennisé tous les ans à
partir d'autres d'autres énigmes bien
sûr et qui nous amèneront peut-être à
travailler en collaboration avec
d'autres sites internet pour faire
découvrir aussi d'autres sources ce
potentiel est là le jeu tout se passe
sur votre site
c'est différent de gueule d'ange où il y
avait des animations c'est sur le site
oui se passe sur notre site on vous l'a
dit ça s'adresse à tout le monde mais
est ce qu'il ya une limite d'âge
il n'y a pas de limite d'âge sachant
néanmoins que le concours est assez
relevé
les énigmes l'énigme n'est pas évidente
comme je disais il ya un concours qui
est spécialement dédié aux collégiens
vinoy donc on estime que c'est à peu
près au niveau collège que l'énigme et
est accessible
vous avez des vite fait les prix est ce
qu'on peut avoir un petit exemple c'est
très bon prix à gagner effectivement il
y aura des tablettes numériques des des
consoles de jeux des trottinettes
électriques des ordinateurs des
appareils photographiques en faire
beaucoup de choses numérique en tout cas
j'imagine c'est un moyen de donner envie
aux participants d'aller fouiller dans
les archives qu'on y trouve pour
peut-être à faire d'autres projets plus
tard lui on souhaite vraiment qu'à
travers son concours on puisse à la fois
faire découvrir les ressources qui sont
disponibles en ligne permettre aux
collégiens aussi d'exercer leur lors
leurs critiques à travers la découverte
des documents mais aussi la
confrontation des sources se confronter
aux originaux pour vraiment décrypter ce
qu'est une actualité confronté faire
faire montre d'esprit critique de
déduction voilà c'est l'idée c'est
vraiment de permettre de découvrir la
richesse de nos collections et de nos
fonds aux traverses ce type de concours
on sent bien aux archives une volonté de
rang des recherches et l'histoire
ludique et notamment mercredi 24
septembre donc il ya seul moyen dont 25
septembre avait présenté au public un
jeu de société qui s'appelle réseau
trois ans de travail mais c'est la
seconde guerre mondiale cette fois
voilà on part sur une autre thématique
mais toujours avec le souci de
sensibilisés aux ressources à travers
des aspects ludiques
il y avait une gueule d'ange qui était
un jeu sérieux en ligne on a cette fois
ci souhaité décliner un jeu de plateau
donc physiques qui permettent de se
confronter à la résistance la thématique
de la résistance donc les joueurs
incarnent un réseau de résistance est à
travers ça ils vont perdre
ils vont pouvoir découvrir ce qu'étaient
les formes de résistance son évolution à
travers le temps les difficultés et les
dangers encourus
ce jeu s'adresse aux collégiens mais
aussi à je dirais à l'ensemble des
personnes désireuses de découvrir
l'histoire puisque le jeu est une
première forme d'appropriation mais il
est complété par d'autres ressources
dira plus sérieuse puisque déjà à
l'intérieur de chaque boîte de jeu on
pourra trouver une brochure pédagogique
historique qui permet de
recontextualiser et de décrypter les
éléments de jeux qui sont mis en oeuvre
dans cette boîte c'est un jeu qui peut
sont présentés sur trois semaines toutes
les infos sont disponibles sur le site
internet
merci au nom du gars d'avoir accepté
notre invitation pour participer à l'
enquête policière rendez vous sur le
site internet des archives et vous avez
jusqu'au 18 octobre pour y participer
du 28 septembre au 6 octobre c'est la
semaine de l'environnement à plaisir une
semaine pour sensibiliser à la gestion
des déchets au climat et à la
préservation de la biodiversité la
commune démarre sa programmation avec
une grande journée de nettoyage et le 2
octobre c'est une balade contée qui vous
attend
le parc du château va vous dévoiler ses
secrets rendez vous à 14 heures à la
médiathèque du château à l'itinéraire a
été préparé par les bibliothécaires et
l'animatrice de la création séoul écoute
faire un petit ramassage des déchets
voilà montrer l'impact d'un déchet sur
le milieu ont ramassé le vert
le verbe ce qu'on va retomber du verre
papiers mégots et leur montrer combien
de temps ça peut se dégrader dans un
milieu naturel montré que bat
normalement naturellement c'est ce sont
les petites bêtes les champignons qui
dégradent tout ça et que c'est sûr que
du verre sépare c'est pas leur
nourriture
et si vous êtes plus tenté par un cinéma
gaël paineau le responsable du grenier à
sel vous propose deux films en avant
première écoute et au cinéma le grenier
à sel nous avons eu un énorme coup de
coeur pour le film papicha de mounia
meddour c'est un film qui a eu pas mal
de récompenses notamment pour la
réalisatrice et l'actrice principale
donc mounia meddour la réalisatrice et
lina caudry l'actrice principale
nous sommes à alger dans les années 90
donc les années sombres en algérie et le
personnage joué par l'ina à caudry elle
s'appelle nedjma ces tunnels à 18 ans
elle est étudiante et elle veut devenir
styliste
elle crée elle même ses propres romans
ses propres vêtements dans le cadre de
la cité universitaire où aller et s'est
laissé la période effectivement où
l'extrémiste prendre l'ampleur et elle
décide de ne rien lâcher on suit cette
aventure qui est un petit peu
autobiographique puisque la réalisatrice
a été elle-même étudiante
a alger dans les années 90 on profite
aussi de toute la richesse d'alger le
langage le front arabe et je vous
conseille vraiment de venir le voir nous
l'avons donc en avant première le
vendredi 4 octobre à 20h45 et notre
deuxième coup de coeur c'est shawn la
ferme contre attaque donc les studios
aardman nous régale d'un film de science
fiction avec ses personnages en pâte à
modeler nous l'avons donc en avant
première dans le cadre de la journée
européenne du cinéma d'art et essai ce
sera le dimanche 13 octobre à 15 heures
[Musique]
ce week-end du côté du sport c'est la
grande classique de la course à pied la
42e édition de paris versailles qui se
déroulait dimanche prochain un départ
donné à la tour eiffel en direction du
château de versailles son président nous
parle du lieu emblématique de la course
quand on parle de paris versailles tout
le monde parle de la côte parce que ces
noms de kilomètres de côtes et puis ce
milieu de la course ont pour certains ça
commence à peser un petit peu et puis
donc oui je décide ces fameux de
kilomètres avec beaucoup de dénivelé
fait que partout on entend parler de la
course paris versailles partout on parle
de la côte et il est aussi question de
solidarité ce week-end à magny les
hameaux tout d'abord la toute jeune
association ensemble vous propose une
promenade familiale en compagnie de
morgan et étienne de jeunes handicapés
le départ est prévu à 11 heures sur le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville suivi d'un
pique nique vers 12h30
avant de découvrir une exposition et
d'échangés sur le thème du handicap du
yoga au profit de mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque l'orangerie du château de
versailles ouvre ses portes ce dimanche
pour une séance d'une heure trente les
fonds récoltés iront pour sauver trois
enfants un atelier est aussi proposée
pour les enfants de 6 à 12 ans c'est la
fin du set loisirs on se retrouve jeudi
prochain
[Musique]